[Music]
when you were playing there was an
Unwritten rule it can be such a tough
violent sport there was an Unwritten
rule you don't hit well Wayne Gretzky
now
that you were that you were that you
were so important to the sport that
opposing teams do you think that's true
no it's not true in a sense that I would
come home some games and I remember
getting up the next day and Janet is
saying to me wow you know don't go to
practice today and I said no we practice
every day I gotta go so I got hit I
didn't get hit as much as people
probably wanted me to get hit especially
on the opposing teams but listen I knew
it was time to retire when I was playing
my last year and people I was playing
against before they would hit me they
would scream my name and say hey heads
up for a wing get out of the way or here
we are
wow okay something's not right about
this I don't want to be the guy that
kills Wayne gretzko yeah I was broke out
Wayne here I come
and the hockey players have so much
respect for each other and it's such a
physical game we went to a Kings game
about two years ago and I have three or
two children after I retired and We the
Kings are always kind enough they let me
sit on the ice and we're sitting there
and these players today are good they're
big they're fast they're strong and
after the first period we got up and my
wife and I and my my two little kids and
my 11 year old son at the time turned to
my wife and said okay be really honest
did Dad really play in this league
right so
um wow the game has changed the game has
changed well let's talk about your style
because it was so uh you were not the
biggest player you were not the fastest
player but like some other remarkable
athletes you just seem to have a sense
of where to be other players would say
that Wayne Gretzky knows how the play is
going to unfold you could see it is that
do you feel that that's safe to say
probably that was my forte my my hockey
sense and and probably started because
at the age of five I remember I said to
my dad I want to try out for a hockey
team and my dad said okay let's go we're
going to try out for this team and at
that time you tried out for 10 year olds
because nobody played before that and I
made this team at 10 years old but
throughout my whole career I was always
sort of the smallest guy and I always
was sort of not the fastest guy or the
toughest guy so my game never changed
from the time I played it started
competing at five to the time I turned
Pro when I turned pro at 17 I weighed
147 pounds
147 pounds my own teammates were nervous
I was going to get hurt yeah and your
Technique which was so fascinating they
would call it uh they would call it your
office you had a an area sort of behind
the net where you could hang out and
that was where you like to go and you
could sort of control the whole flow of
the game for your team from there well I
was one of the first guys to start it
used to be that the centerman sort of
stood in the slot guys like Phyllis
Esposito guys like John rattel and they
were bigger and stronger guys I couldn't
stand there I would get the crap beat
out of me and so I had a coach when I
was 14 years old said go watch this guy
Bobby Clark play and watch how he plays
he's not very big he's smart he passes
the puck and he plays sort of from the
corner and a little bit behind the net
and so at the age of 14 I started
watching him day in and day out and he
probably had the most influence of my
career as far as learning how to play
the game and the style game that I
played and so I learned to play behind
the net and when I started doing that it
was so unique nobody had ever tried to
defend that and so I was able to really
Master it and become really good at it
and that was sort of my forte and your
record 92 goals in one season right many
people think many sports writers think
that's a goal that's never going to be
touched it's going to be like DiMaggio's
uh you know hitting streak do you do you
do you have a theory on that do you
think in your lifetime there's some punk
kids going to come along
get 93.
uh you know what records are made to be
broken and when I grew up my idol was
Gordie Howe and he couldn't have been
any nicer couldn't have been any better
he's just a really good man and so when
I broke his records he was always the
first guy there so if anybody's ever
breaks my records they'll be the first
guy to shake his hand the players are
good today there's a lot of good players
that you know never is a long time but
to me when I got the 50 goals in 39
games that's the record to me that I
think will be the hardest one to break
because 50 goals in 38 games with a lot
of goals
yes
I've come
[Music]
it's pretty good we'll see you know